[Music]
first ethnically accurate Jesus goes
right here next to Father Mary and
mother Josephine followed closely by the
three gender less wise people on their
bird scooters TIG nataro for some reason
and of course the Little Drummer them
because God forbid we call a boy a
boy is the season to be trans or
something like that I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Ruben report it's December 6 2023
we are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals share tap that subscription
button the notification bell all of
those things and if you want to join us
for the postgame as always Ruben report.
locals.com and yes because it is the it
is it
is it is the season to be jolly Dave
ruin. store we've got some new stuff
hoodies mugs t-shirts there's all kinds
of stuff over there Dave ruin. store uh
today's show is I would say a
culmination in many ways of my life's
work I have spent the last couple years
trying to explain to many people across
the interwebs that the wokers the
lefties the collectivists that these
people have completely lost their mind
and that we have to take them seriously
because while they have purple hair and
they don't know what genitals are
attached to their body they are
destroying absolutely everything and I
think subsequently over the last couple
years people have sort of realized it
more and more you know years ago people
used to say oh don't worry they're just
a bunch of crazy college kids but when
they get out into the real world the
real world will show them what's up but
I think we've seen that the real world
in many cases has just folded to them
that the ideas that they have learned in
these colleges are all the wrong ideas
and then they have then brought these
ideas into our institutions our
corporate atmosphere our governmental
institutions all of these things and now
everything seems to be collapsing but
yesterday there was a congressional
hearing that might have been the most
incredible example of how evil this
ideology is and how deeply it has
infected our colle is uh the presidents
of Harvard MIT and Penn were brought in
front of Congress to discuss what's
going on with the crazed anti-Semitism
and calls for genocide and violence and
vandalism that's happening on their
campuses and they were asked a bunch of
different questions and we're going to
show you some absolutely Wild video like
it is unbelievably staggering what's
going on there we're going to compare
that of course with some of the people
who've been warning about all of this
stuff for years and then maybe at the
end we'll figure out a way to see if
there's a better way to uh deal with the
world rather than burning everything
down but I want to start uh with the new
president of Argentina as you know
Javier Malay the libertarian who we're
being told is far right just because he
believes in limited government and low
taxes and he doesn't want to fund all of
these crazy social justice programs uh
he is the new president of Argentina and
he ran on a radically anti-woke
antisocial Justice platform Because he
believes the ideas of collectivism are
the wor set of ideas they only destroy
they do not
create Argentina has been in a lot of
trouble for 20 years he's got crazy hair
it's quite a uh I would say a package
with this guy uh here he is explaining
why social justice is the ultimate
[Music]
injus
e
Al
okay let me recap that for those of you
uh who are listening on the audio
podcast who maybe don't speak Spanish in
essence while quoting Milton Freedom
Freedman and a couple other uh great
thinkers he's saying that the idea of
liberalism that we would all be equal
before the law that this is a just idea
this was a good idea that is the that is
the Bedrock idea of Western civil ations
but it is counter to the idea of social
justice that we will give and
redistribute based on these
characteristics and we will take from
some who produce and give to others
based on whatever reason the people in
power want to give that is what he is
trying to unfurl right now in Argentina
because they have had one of the most
woke governments for the last 20 years
before the word woke had become
ubiquitous they had all of these crazy
government programs they destroyed their
own economy they had gender programs in
the government and all of the absolute
lunacy so he's calmly laying out that
the idea of true liberalism is good but
it has nothing to do obviously with the
modern progressivism and wokeism and
social justice movement and all that now
before I get to what happened yesterday
in Congress I want to jump back to a
video from 2018 this is one of the
videos this might be the video actually
that put Jordan Peterson on the map when
he did this interiew interview uh with
British quote unquote journalist Kathy
Newman uh he here explains this isn't
the part that made him go viral uh but
this is another piece of the the Jordan
Peterson puzzle and I think it'll frame
what we're doing today very nicely uh
here he is explaining 2018 5 years ago
that the philosophy that is guiding the
left the philosophy that's guiding the
social justice Warriors the wers the
collectivists the Neo racists all of
those people right right it's a big
swath of people that it's the exact same
philosophy of ma dong who killed about
100 million of his own people take a
look well except you've also called
trans campaigners authoritarian haven't
you I mean isn't that only in the
broader context of my claims that
radical leftist ideologues are
authoritarian which they are you're
saying someone who is trying to work out
their gender identity who may well have
struggled with that had quite a tough
time over years you're comparing them
with you know chairman m who saw the
deaths of millions of people well even
if the activists you know they're trans
people too they have a right to say
these things yeah but they don't
have compare them to Chairman ma or you
know I could pin austo pinache I mean
you know this is grossly insensitive I
didn't compare them to pinish I did
compare them he was an authoritarian he
was a right winger though I was
comparing them to the left wi
totalitarians and I do believe they are
left totalitarians under ma millions of
people died I mean there's no comparison
between Ma and a trans activist is there
why not because trans activist aren't
killing millions of people the
philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same
philosophy yes that last line there so
Kathy Newman ain't that bright we all
know that what you really remember Kathy
Newman from is the what was the exact
line she said so what you're saying is
remember she just couldn't understand
Jordan she repeated kept saying so what
you're saying is but Kathy Newman there
seems to not understand and I'll give
her a little bit of credit in that this
is 5 years ago what Jordan's trying to
explain is that the totalitarian
ideology of someone like Mao Z dang
could lead to the death of 100 million
of his own people because he wanted to
form this perfect Society what Jordan is
cleanly and clearly laying out and she's
clearly offended by is the idea that the
these trans activists these radical
Lefty activists and again he's saying
this five years ago that what sits
within them is the ability to kill an
awful lot of people not that they're
doing it yet not that they're right on
the precipice of doing it although 5
years later here we are in 2023 and we
have calls for genocide throughout our
universities but it's the he's not
comparing Mao dong the leader to the
trans activist so specifically he's
saying the ideology the totalitarian way
of if I had enough control and if I
could order societies the way I wanted
and get rid of all those imperfections
which means getting rid of a lot of
people I would do it and that has become
very obvious so now this is going to get
us to what happened uh in the halls of
Congress yesterday it's absolutely wild
but before we talk about that let me see
if I can get through this manscaped ad
properly guys Merry balls from our
friends over at manscaped the holidays
are approaching but what if I told you
that the celebrations are starting early
this year it turns out that the perfect
gift does exist and who else to bring
bring it down your chimney than the
leaders in waist in below the waist
grooming keep calm and let your balls
jingle this season with manscapes brand
new performance package 5.0 Ultra
featuring the new lawn mower 5.0 watch
all your wishes and mistletoe kisses
come true look nice when you're going to
be naughty by going to manscape.com and
using Code Dave for 20% off plus free
shipping manscapes performance package
5.0 Ultra is the ultimate bundle for the
man who deserves it all included in this
special sack is the lawnmower 5.0 Ultra
the weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose
trimmer manscapes liquid formulations
and two free gifts now that you've
groomed the candy cane it's time to make
sure you don't smell like a reindeer
with the crop Soo After Shave lotion and
crop preserver anti- ball chafe
deodorant once they touch your sack
you'll never go back the gift of
manscape doesn't stop there two free
gifts that come with this bundle or
manscape boxers 2.0 premium underwear
and the shed 2.0 toiletry bag these are
seriously the best boxers I've ever worn
in fact I'm wearing them right now but
I'm not going to show you not kind of
show get 20% off and free shipping with
the code Dave manscape.com that's 20%
off with free shipping at
manscaped.com use code Dave manscaped
get your jingle balls ready for the
holidays H H come on I did it all right
so I started with incoming Argentinian
president Javier Malay laying out the
difference between liberalism
equality versus social justice right
then we played a video of Jordan
Peterson explaining to Kathy Newman that
the
totalitarian ideology that drove someone
like ma dong who killed a 100 million of
his own people in the Quest for
Perfection a perfect Society is the same
thing that's driving the trans activists
of today he was talking about that in
2018 now I want to bring you uh to
yesterday uh so there was a
congressional hearing where they got the
president of MIT of University uh upen
and Harvard and they drag them out there
to go what the high hell is going on
with the anti-Semitism on your campuses
these protests and blocking buildings
and attacking students and vandalizing
stuff and all all of the stuff that you
get uh so representative she's from New
York Republican Elise stefanic asked MIT
president Sally cornbluth and Penn
president Liz McGill if it's K to call
for the genocide of the Jews I might
recommend that before we play this clip
that you adjust yourself and make sure
you're sitting in your seat securely
because you might actually fall out of
your
chair Dr corn Blu does m at MIT does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
mit's code of conduct or rules regarding
bullying and harassment yes or no if
targeted at individuals not making
public
statements yes or no calling for the
genocide of Jews does not constitute
bullying and harassment I have not heard
calling for the genocide for Jews on our
campus but you've heard chance for
in I've heard chance which can be
anti-semitic depending on the context
when calling for the elimination of the
Jewish people so those would not be
according to the mit's code of conduct
or
rules that would be um investigated of
as harassment if pervasive and severe
Miss Gil at Penn does calling for the
genocide of Jews violate Penn's rules or
code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
McGill so is your testimony that you
will not answer yes if it uh is if the
speech becomes if the speech becomes
conduct it can be harassment yes conduct
meaning committing the act of
genocide the speech is not harassment
this is unacceptable Miss Migel I'm
going to give you one more opportunity
for the world to see your answer does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
pens code of conduct when it comes to
bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes you know I've watched this five
times this morning and I'm still almost
speechless first off that lady there at
the end um the smile she's smiling the
whole time like I think the devil is in
her like she has been possessed by the
devil I don't know that I exactly mean
that literally but I kind of do in in a
real spiritual sense these people have
become rotten from the inside uh there
was so much obfuscation there first off
I want to give real credit can we can we
try to get Alise stepanic on the show I
think we we almost had her on about a
year ago I want to try to get her on the
show she did an absolutely great job
very cleanly clearly laying out come on
now like come on I'm giving you a chance
here the whole world's watching and the
Devil Woman with that smile uh you have
to also remember before I get into some
of the specifics these schools for the
last five seven years we have been told
that these kids should be issued
microaggressions and Trigger warnings
and they should be told if they're going
to be discussing something that might
upset them and everything else and
they're you know the generation
Snowflake and we shouldn't upset them
and it's their truth and all of these
things suddenly when it comes to calling
for extermination of one particular
minority well as one of them said only
when speech turns into conduct and as
Alise stepanic said yes that would be
the genocide so you can defend free
speech and also say uh you know if you
keep calling for genocide we're going to
kill all the Jews or all that that
actually is harassment a school is
allowed to have a harassment policy
right that that they can have their own
uh rules and regulations around but for
her to say it's only when it turns into
conduct so you could be wandering down
the streets kill all the Jews everybody
kill all Jews you want to kill some Jews
come on we're taking a walk we're going
to go kill all the Jews and there's
Jewish students around they're going you
know I'd prefer not to be killed today
this seems this seems a little bit crazy
and that their University's only uh
ability to do anything would be after
the conduct had occurred so after the oh
look there's a bunch of dead Jews there
well we should have done something about
that it is it is so extraordin it
shouldn't the thing is this shouldn't
surprise anybody even though I've
watched it five times and even though
I'm we're going to go into some of the
people that are discussing this now and
talking about this on Twitter and
elsewhere this is what the end of social
justice would look like it would look
like a bunch of smiling smug disgusting
College presidents defending calling for
genocide making sure that there were no
rules and regulations followed at their
universities as far as what you could
call for when you're protesting and
whether you were allowed to take over
buildings and everything else anyway it
continued here is Elise stefanic asking
Harvard president Claudine
gay the same question and Dr Gay at
Harvard does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or no it can be
depending on the context what's the
context targeted as an individual
targeted as at an individual it's
targeted at Jewish students Jewish
individuals do you understand your
testimony is dehumanizing them do you
understand that dehumanization is part
of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or no anti-semitic
rhetoric when and is anti-Semitic
rhetoric anti-semitic rhetoric when it
crosses into conduct that amounts to
bullying harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
[Music]
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the board this is so
extraordinary I want to I just want to
make the distinction again she's not
talking about what the first amendment
allows what these people when they call
for the Gen genocide of the Jews or when
they're calling for River to the sea or
any of those things they're trying to
intentionally get as close as they
possibly can to a violation of the First
Amendment right like they're using our
rules against us that's one thing but
that's not what stepanic is asking about
here she's saying what are the policies
of the school you guys when kids come to
the school you get a booklet or a
pamphlet or something and it's a
bullying and harassment pamphlet try to
imagine it this way try to imagine it
this way imagine if there was a whole
bunch of white kids rampaging through
Harvard calling for the genocide of
black people what do you think Harvard
would be doing right now Connor you're
white give me give me something on this
one they would not allow it according to
White
Conor they wouldn't allow it and we all
know they wouldn't allow it and they
shouldn't allow it they have their
policy related to buling arrestment the
fact that this dingbat Miss gay Dr Gay
which is like just so perfect for
related to all Dr Gay um but the fact
that Dr Gay is like well you know really
it's again when it turns into conduct
okay so when we have 10 dead Jews
hanging into Harvard Square would that
be enough for you would that be a
problem anyway thankfully everyone with
their head on straight and there still
are a couple people uh are calling this
out for the abject lunacy that it is
here's Elon Musk who know is not an
anti-semite let me help them out here
calling for the genocide death of anyone
obviously constitutes harassment again
this is their own policies related to
bullying and harassing right so this is
separate from the First Amendment itself
so once again Elon Musk just doing the
right thing the thing that we all know
but that these corrupt mind muddled
social justice freaks who have been
given you know jobs that these people
are probably paid three or $400,000 a
year to do um it's just disgusting
anyway Jordan Peterson he saw it he said
I simply cannot believe what I just
heard and saw all three of these women
should immediately resign hanging their
heads in shame the mighty have truly uh
fallen and he tagged Harvard and MIT
obviously Penn was the other one there
uh and I got one more for you this was
particularly interesting I thought Eric
Weinstein who obviously is a friend of
the show been on many times this is this
is really something my undergraduate
University Penn my PhD University
Harvard and my postdoctoral University
MIT all walk into a hearing three for
three this is like the setup of a
personalized anti-semitic can joked from
hell what I would like to say to the
Presidents of all three institutions you
just aren't good enough for these
institutions this is not revolutionary
Marxist Justice finger painting daycare
for sociopaths enough Dei enough
normalization of hatred have someone
else who understands Academia science
and research take over uh he links to a
video that's regarding a takeback MIT
stance that he did with Lex Freeman a
couple years ago um I would uh caveat
what Eric said there with one which with
one thing which is um they will not it's
not that they won't step down maybe one
or two of them eventually over the next
year or two will step down and they'll
have some excuse these places are rotted
all the way through I said it before and
I will say it again and I will never
hire someone from an ivy league
university uh we just brought on uh a
new guy who's moving to Florida next
week Joey and he's a College Dropout
this guy's a College Dropout over here
you finished College I'm gonna hold that
against you when we do when we do end
the year bonuses in a couple weeks sorry
buddy you went you're getting a little
something extra we dropping out um
college is a brain destroying machine
that's all it is you will be lucky if
your child comes out of college without
waving a Hamas flag and with their
original genitals intact and you will
have paid 150 grand for that privilege
it is completely insane but let's
continue here's Dr Gay again I love this
woman Dr Gay she's the bad guy in in a
Austin Powers movie Dr Gay is asked if
foreign governments are actually funding
some of the Middle East Studies classes
at Harvard that are teaching the kids
that Hamas are the good guys we received
funding from iety of sources because we
have alumni from all over the world but
that is correct right the Middle Eastern
studies Department we receive funding
from various sources yes or no are you
not aware where the Middle Eastern
studies Department receives funding we
receive funding from I am asking you a
yes or no question you are under oath in
front of the United States Congress you
were giving lip service provided to your
attorneys it's a yes or no question
Harvard receives funding from foreign
entities and governments which support
its middle Middle Eastern studies
Department correct we have alumni all
over the world and we benefit correct
their philanthropy yes the answer is
correct we receive support from our
alumni from all over the world from
individuals and what amount of support
is that reported to the federal
government I'd have to actually look at
our filings you don't know as the
president University you don't know not
that particular number it's $1.5 billion
over the past three years are you aware
of
that I don't know if that is the correct
number but that's the number you sh I'm
pretty sure I'm going to give stepanic a
little credit here I'm pretty sure the
1.5 bill over three years think about
that forign donors and governments 1.5
Bill to Harvard on top can you Google
how much is the Harvard endowment right
now Harvard is sitting on what is it's
36 billion you just knew that off the
top of your head wow and this guy didn't
even go to college
um they are sitting on $36 billion I'll
take your word for it 50 billion 50
billion all right you ballparked it it's
okay they're sitting on $50 billion they
got in the last three years $1.5 billion
from foreign alumni and government okay
stepanic knows that she's in Congress
and that Dr Gay over there is testifying
under oath and they refuse to ever say
anything true these people there is
nothing to say about them at this point
other than that they are so deeply
corrupt that they have now turn they
have turned the corner into being
profoundly evil but let's continue with
Dr Gay uh because here she is and we
know that Harvard has had these Hamas
rallies all over the place some Jewish
kids have been have had to hide in their
rooms their rooms have been uh
vandalized one Jewish kid got punched by
somebody from Harvard Divinity School
because Divinity I guess ain't what it
used to be uh so Dr Gay was asked is
Harvard facilitating a hostile
anti-Semitic environment on campus
Harvard by the way which back in the day
now they discriminate mostly against
Asian people with quotas they used to
back in the day have quotas against Jews
because Jews were working too hard and
paying attention to the right things too
much they didn't want too many Jews
there they still are not thrilled with
Jews but watch she watch this watch this
as you know Harvard received for over
the last four years 3.2 billion in
federal grants and contracts uh during
the 2021 school year Harvard received
104 million through title 4 why should
Congress continue to invest money in
Harvard when Harvard clearly violates
title six and helps Foster a hostile
Jewish hostile environment for Jewish
students we are committed at at Harvard
to ensuring that all of our students
Thrive that they feel safe and secure
well apparently 100 professors who 100
professors who sent that letter to you
criticizing your condemnation of
anti-semitic remarks don't agree with
that and your students your institution
is clearly producing students who are
sympathetic to a terrorist organization
don't you think that's a misuse of
taxpayer
dollars my time is expired I she's just
got nothing she's got nothing do you
understand your tax dollars go to these
universities it is it is a giant
extraordinary grift we've got more from
Dr
Gay so you would not want such a person
to be part of the community those are
not consistent with Harvard values would
you want someone who has called for the
eradication of the Jewish people uh to
be part of the Harvard community
again those are not consistent with
Harvard values where we are committed to
making would you want someone who has
called for the elimination of the state
of Israel to be part of the Harvard
Community there is no place at Harvard
for anti-Semitism but the elimination of
the state of Israel someone who
advocates for that is that someone you'd
want to be part of the Harvard Community
there is no place for anti-Semitism at
Harvard you're not answering my
questions very well Dr Gabe so the woman
cannot answer the question honestly
we've now shown you what four clips of
her in no clip there did she answer
anything honestly and we all know it she
is fostering this this is what her
University is about this is the we are
seeing it in real time right now the end
of social justice is taking a minority
who figures out through years of
education and tradition and religion and
belief and a whole bunch of stuff
figures out how not to be oppressed
despite it being a minority it figures
out how to succeed and Thrive because of
liberal values that offer equality it
does that right and then at the end at
the most Lefty Elite colleges it is now
thrown under the bus right that's
exactly what they're doing to the Jews
at Harvard everyone knows it and you
have University presidents who who will
not stand up and and say anything
remotely close to True uh here she is uh
she also apparently Dr I can't take this
Dr Gay this is this better be our do
last Dr gay if we have any more Dr Gay
in this I'm I'm not doing it one more
from Dr Gay uh because there were pramas
protesters they were vandalizing things
and attacking students and they were
doing a whole bunch of you know just
marching through dorms and which that
could be upsetting you know if someone
is marching through your dorm saying I'd
like to kill everyone and your your
grandma yeah I'd love to kill her that
could be upsetting to some kids uh she
seems unclear as to whether anyone was
disciplined for doing of this stuff why
did you allow protesters to occupy
University hall for 24 hours and not
only were these students not punished
but two of your Deans provided them them
with food and promised no disciplinary
action would be taken and that was
reported by the Harvard Crimson I can
assure you that we have very strong
disciplinary processes and where conduct
violates our policies we did violate
your policies during processes
underway so is there an answer to that
or
not we have disciplinary processes
underway so was any discipline action I
I love the lip service I do and you
academic I love that I'm looking for an
action item yes no was anybody expelled
any action item and if you don't know
that's okay too we hold our community to
account I'll policies I actually don't
know much about congresswoman mlan but I
I like her cuz basically I'm going to
curse you ready it's okay she basically
is like off gay we've had enough of
this that's what and and that
is the truth right we're looking into
well we did sure he did call for killing
all the Jews and that kid got punched
and you know they
were like off
gay uh here's 15 seconds of uh some of
the Jordan thing I showed you a moment
ago now I want you to think about what
Jordan is saying here and see if it's
applicable to everything that we just
showed you I mean there's no comparison
between Ma and a trans activist is there
why not because trans activists aren't
killing millions of people the
philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same
philosophy yes it is the same philosophy
it is the same philosophy so that these
Elite universities cannot do anything
other than actually inst at the fires
while their students are calling for
genocide against their own students but
we should not be surprised by any of
this this has infected everything so now
I've got a video of ibram X kendi and
ibram ibram X kendi is sort of the great
um he he in some ways I hate to give the
guy too much credit but he's kind of the
architect of Every Which Way that woke
has infected all of our cultural
institutions and especially at a at a
television level and uh here he is this
guy's racist this guy is a racist mfer
that's all he is he has no true
understanding of Freedom or America or
anything else but what does that lead to
if you're just like a Neo racist and you
happen to be black you're going to get a
gig at Netflix and they're going to pay
you a whole bunch of money to put out
some racist programming for guilty white
people so here's ibram kendi getting a
giant Round of Applause at a Netflix
screaming uh screening uh of his new
show while of course demonizing white
people I guess that was just a bonus but
take a look I I don't think uh White uh
people were wide have really reckoned
with how much their own personal
identity is shaped by constructions of
whiteness and and how
much um that construction of
whiteness uh
prevents uh white people from uh
connecting to Humanity in other words uh
recognizing that uh when you when you
recognize that you are part and parcel
of humanity in other words you're not
over Humanity right uh it it allows you
to really be able to connect to people
who don't look like you who have kinky
hair who have dark skin in uh and to see
yourself in them and it's whiteness that
prevents that right and and when you're
not able to see
yourself uh in other human
beings that creates all sorts of
problems um but not just societal
problems personal problems that that I
think hopefully this this this film and
this work will will liberate those folks
from so I I think it's this liberate
it's liberating all the way around right
it it
you know I think it it will liberate you
know really all of us because you know
we've all been told a lie about
ourselves and other
people oh oh my god oh that is incred
first off everything he said there was
complete epic also I'm pretty
sure he culturally appropriated his
dreadlocks from the Predator uh also
Connor I'd like to ask you because you
are a representative you're our main
white you're our White you guys are both
white but you're but you're our main
whitest person here uh he said that
whiteness prevents you from connecting
to
humanity would you does that would you
say that's applicable to you yeah like
you're a pretty nice guy people like
Connor everybody loves Connor you've
been unable to connect with Humanity due
to your whiteness it's it's all just
like they literally put words together
and then a bunch of guilty morons pay
them to do it to put it on oh my God I
should connect with my human I'm white
what am I going to do he continues we're
really just hitting people over the head
with this today between Dr Gay and
this Dr fraud go I actually do think
that uh white Americans and white people
worldwide can begin to recognize the
full scope of their privilege and and
part of the reason why I think that's
the case is because as a man you know
I've been seeking to and on a journey to
recognize the full scope of my privilege
as a man right you know as a
heterosexual man um now people around me
may tell me well you haven't done that
yet right but but I feel like I'm
genuinely trying I'm genuinely striving
um I'm genuinely also
recognizing the ways in which um you
know masculinity can be toxic not just
to the world but even to men um
and so I'm I'm hoping that if I as a man
uh can can recognize that privilege then
then then white people as white people
can recognize their privileges as well
wow look at this guy he knows what a man
is he thinks just because he has a wang
he's a man I'm very very impressed the
whole scope of whiteness and the white
people's privilege you know I want to
say something about Netflix the reason
I'm showing you these clips is because
you may think okay this guy's just some
like AC mic blah he's not even an
academic whatever he is he's just some
fraudster but you probably have Netflix
I have Netflix I have Netflix and I
don't know how much longer I can have it
I'm almost done through the crown I'm
about to finish up the crown and I watch
Seinfeld on Netflix I just got to get a
DVD player could one of you for Chris
Mika can one of you get me a DVD player
and get me all night and all nine
seasons of Seinfeld could you do that
and then I'm just done with Netflix we
this is what I mean we are paying for
our own demise I canceled Disney plus a
long time ago we're all just deciding
like think about Netflix pays that guy
to promote racism and then you sit your
kid in front of that television and they
put on something to learn about how
racist they are and if you don't think
they're angling it towards kids well
watch this here's another panelist on
stage with ebram kendi who's in this new
show that they're putting out on Netflix
and uh well they're very excited because
they're going to really start editing
this thing and push it more more to the
kids because the kids need more of
this what do what do I have next I am
doing a stamp from the beginning impact
campaign we made this film to change
Hearts minds and policy and I am trying
to work with our team of producers to
make sure that it does just that we want
it to re-edit it so that we can get it
to middle schoolers we want to create
curriculum we want to uh we want to do
an annotated website and more because it
is crucial crucially important that
children of all kinds grow up
understanding there's nothing wrong with
with black people but also grow up
understanding that they have a right
they have a obligation and they have the
power to make change for everybody so
that's what I'm working on
[Music]
next Bard I mean no one's growing up
thinking there's anything wrong with
black people congratulations you guys
are well you guys aren't particularly
good but it has very little to do with
the fact that your skin color is black
it's because you've been infected with
all of the wrong ideas and now you are
being paid by
Netflix to infect everyone else with
those bad ideas so they want to take
Iam's new show whatever the hell the
show is it doesn't even matter and then
they want to now edit it so it can be
put in curriculum into middle schools
and people will allow us well we ain't
going to have it in Florida but if you
want to see what else uh Netflix is
doing as you know it's not just making
your kids think that they're racist and
you feeling guilty about your whiteness
and oppressiveness and all that stuff uh
they are also trying to chop your
children's genitals off here's a show
called big mouth on
Netflix gay yeah I did kind of think you
were gay so did I but then I sang this
duet with the ghost of Freddy Mercury
sure as one does gay totally gay and I
realized that didn't feel right either
it was something more than that what's
your problem kid I don't know I just
know I hate you and what you're doing to
my body nobody likes puberty that's why
they made the show it was like I was
vibrating at this weird frequency all
the time hey I get it but then I found
this for for Trans kids and it was like
that's who I am so I told my parents oh
God did they freak out sort of yeah but
then my mom started listening to Lady
Gaga and sadly that's what made her come
around don't love but go on I like that
movie where a boyfriend pisses pants at
the gramys so we decided I should go on
hormone blockers all right right let's
get you some tow
here you I was going to make you such a
man you were going to have dry knees and
the confidence to wear flipflops with
long nails and now you'll never write
for
billb and now I'm here and the boys are
dicks and the girls are also dicks but
like in a more decimating way yes what
is up with them guys look anyone can
make whatever art they want and you have
to decide if you want to pay for it and
you have to decide what you want to put
your kids in front of and see how that
infects them um I don't think there's a
problem with being gay my husband's gay
I'm gay after 10 p.m. okay it's fine
it's just fine it's not something that
you have to scream about or make a big
deal about really something I usually
just do in my own home
um but but these people push and then I
went on hormone blockers and I listened
to Lady Gaga and I chopped my wang off
and I it's just absolutely insane but
you know this is being pushed it's being
pushed relentless l ly here's a
compilation of Disney shows going full
woke too the flag stands for us as a
group of people being united and being
with each other in a time of need this
country was built on slavery which means
slaves built this country the flag means
everything to me it means life it means
freedom it also means unity and it means
love we the descendants of slaves in
America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every mon we SP submerged in
the systemic Prejudice racism and white
supremacy all the flags you know you
ride down the street and it makes you
feel connected like we're in this
together we Cate juneth for theth time
our account is still outstanding cuz
this country was built on slavery which
means SL built
this what happened to Disney why was
Disney then like that and now like this
why did Disney chop its own genitals off
and the reason I'm showing you that I
know we've shown you that clip before is
because if they can do that to kids and
if they've been doing that to kids for
years thinking that America's evil and
founded on slavery and if you're a boy
you're actually a girl and all of that
stuff if they can do that to your kids
at 5 years old and seven years old and 9
years old and then you send them to
Harvard where they can chant for
genocide and call the bad guys good and
the good guys bad and then they can get
those kids out of those universities
into all of our uh institutions do you
think our institutions might crumble
over time you know it and guess what
they are doing it intentionally and they
have been telling us they are doing it
intentionally you might remember some of
those Disney production Executives
telling each other how great it is that
they're infecting the minds of kids
video hello and welcome to the Disney
plus this is me Pride Celebration
spectacular texted me this morning you
know jenz is 30 to 40% queerer than the
other Generations mom so Disney better
get with it our leadership over there
has been so welcoming to like my like
not at all secret gay agenda they've
been really open to exploring queer
stories I'm on the production side and
so kind of the only way to have these
like canonical trans characters
canonical asexual characters canonical
bisexual characters is to give them
stories where they can like be their
whole selves I identify as like a
biromantic asexual I want to like add
the pock the the pockets of the lgbtq
community That You Don't See I was like
I want to get like gay advance so we no
longer say ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls it's hello everyone or Hello
friends we were targeting gen Z and and
Millennials we were T targeting a
younger um all this content is going for
to kids who don't know any of this and
even if they're in a household like
Keith uh that have uh supportive parents
they're still getting all of this
information from media of what is normal
oh my God I have to figure out a way to
get a canonical asexual character into
these shows people can't watch shows
that are just without canonical asexual
characters you have to have like six of
them I don't know what it means a
canonical asexual character I don't I
don't know anyone like that in real
life but you know look at me in my beard
and I sound like a woman and that one's
a bisexual Divergent horse over there
and look at that two-spirited queer we
need more representation in the
universities and our programming
and uh if you think all of this is not
being directed top down and there isn't
some sort of War on your mind and your
children and everything that is good and
everything that human beings have fought
for forever uh here's Black Rock CEO uh
explaining that uh yes they are using
forces and economic levers to promote
all of these bad ideas using ESG you
take a look behaviors are going to have
to change and this is one thing we're
going to we're asking
companies uh you have to force behaviors
and at Black Rock we are forcing
behaviors what we are doing internally
is if you don't achieve these levels of
impact your compensation going to be
impacted okay you have to force
behaviors and if you don't force
behaviors whether it's gender or race or
just any way you want to say the
composition of your
team you're going to be
impacted I mean I can't even imagine
anything more evil why do you have to
force
behaviors Connor when you take your
whiteness when you leave this place and
you think about your white I'm not
forcing you to do it it would be nice if
you would evaluate your whiteness and
your white privilege Phoenix you too I
know you have a little darker skin but
still little something would be nice but
I'm not going to force you to what is he
talking about we at Black Rock so what
they do with ESG is they tell these
giant corporations that you must have a
certain amount of black people and a
certain amount of and a certain
amount of people with limps and lesbians
and give me a who is a little
confused about something and build your
team and then suddenly because you don't
do it on skill you actually put
something instead instead of skill and
quality and and and worth and hard work
and dedication instead of focusing on
that meritocracy you then build worse
products and that's why all the Disney
movies suck that's why Disney is purging
money right now that's why the s purely
beat Disney absolutely did beat Disney
but we're almost there people what does
forcing woke ESG Behavior via corporate
fascism remind you of I think I have an
idea I mean there's no comparison
between Ma and a trans activist is there
why not because trans activists aren't
killing millions of people the
philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy
the consequences are not yet you're
saying that trans activists could lead
to the deaths of millions of people what
no I'm saying that the philosophy that
drives their utterances is the same
philosophy that already has driven us to
the deaths of millions of people okay
tell us how that philosophy is in any
way comparable sure that's no problem
the first thing is is that the
philosophy presumes that group identity
is
Paramount that's the fundamental
philosophy that drove the Soviet Union
and ma China and it's the fundamental
philosophy of the left-wing activists
it's identity politics doesn't matter
who you are as an individual it matters
who you are in terms of your group
identity did we lay it on thick enough
for you today I think we completed it
tied it in a bow we're going to shellack
it and mail it out you get it you get it
there has been a plan for a long time to
make this happen as shocking as those
videos are of those University
presidents defending anti-Semitism and
defending calls for for genocide and not
living up to any of their purported
ideals you should not be that shocked
right it's shocking in some in
some some thin layer way but beneath it
if you've been paying attention to
anything that we've been doing here that
many other people have been talking
about and and if you've been following
the trends of which way the Democrat
Party is going and what has happened to
all of our cultural institutions and
everything else none of this should
shock you the real the real question
should be what can you do about it and
you know what you can do about it you
can build new things you can build
better things uh that's what I've tried
to do here that's what rumble's doing
that's what locals is doing that's what
Elon is doing with Twitter right and
that's what my friends at the daily wire
are doing right now is they've gone into
uh movies and they just released the
trailer oh well actually the movie's out
but I want to show you I want to end
today uh with the trailer of their first
ever featurelength comedy lady
ballers in a world where women's sports
is being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
Year guys this is serious sports can be
your pathway to a better life what like
yours please don't steal my catalytic
converter again winning matters it's the
key ingredient and becoming a winner
maybe you should try it
sometime are you going to move I am
not let's cut to the chase I know you're
not a woman hey you don't know how he
identifies if you can beat though what
do you know about the US opens for the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day join this
is the way the world is now my
8-year-old daughter told me all about it
so a guy can become a girl with no
physical changes at all oh that's called
ginger fluid so I can be a woman on the
court and a man in the bedroom I can't
believe it nice you mean when you're
sleeping yes Coach Alex we could play
basketball we'd have to get the whole
team back together it's time we're in
I'm in I'm in to play Lady balers
M you like a girl that's why I'm with
her
[Applause]
in my truth this is my
truth from Heroes day one of being a
girl athlete I love being a girl to Sho
we could dominate every woman's sport
running swimming soccer I said sport
Felix it's ladies basketball Boys Nobody
watches excuse me are these seats open
never mind getting
dunks and tuing
Trunks know she
[Music]
didn't that's the biggest I've ever seen
on a lady I don't care lady
Ballers one can even be trans aged now
which provides sheing with a wonderful
opportunity to relive all the
experiences that she missed out on in
school streaming exclusively on daily
wire
plus God cameos by Ben Shapiro Andrew
claven and many more you guys get the
point build new things these people are
not going to stop the institutions are
not coming back Disney is not coming
back Netflix ain't coming back but
whatever do whatever it is you do
whether you are literally a plumber or a
cleaning person person or you own a
little uh food store or whatever like
build your things the way the way you
want to see Society operate and that is
the only way we will separate from these
people because they are simply not going
to stop and maybe we just have to let
them let them have the wreckage you know
what congratulations guys you did it you
destroyed an awful lot keep that crap
we're on to Greener pastur uh people of
the internet is live at 1 p.m. if you
want to send us a up to a 30 second
video submission if you want to ask me a
question you can do it right now just
email us contact rubben report.com uh as
I've mentioned we have a new Twitter
account for show clips it's Ruben report
show on Twitter the merch store is Dave
ruin. store postgame show right now
Ruben report. locals.com see you
tomorrow is there a problem
people no problem at all Mrs Kennedy we
were just discussing ideas of what to do
with the new Prince Eric movie put a
kick in it make a gay
uh yes Miss Kennedy uh some of the execs
are just expressing that maybe well that
maybe we should go a different route
than we did with Indiana Jones Indiana
Jones put a chicken in and make her L
gay a woman in it make but Mrs Kennedy B
Bambi's a baby deer baby dear put a
chicken in make her gay the inini and
clam sauce uh excuse me I believe I
asked you to put a chicken this and make
her gay uh yes the chef was a little
confused what you meant by that it means
put a chick in the Linguini and make her
G and I want it
[Music]
lame